so Aaron welcome to Microsoft Research
you're here for the the next day or so
to give a distinguished lecture on some
of your recent work on I think
controlling or providing guidelines
guardrails for language generation which
is really interesting when one operates
in the open world you're very well known
in the deep learning community I think
in part because of your book that you
co-authored which sits on our beautiful
bookshelf there with Ian good fellow and
yo Schwab NGO entitled very
descriptively deep learning and it's you
know it's a book that's really shaped I
think the feel and brought a lot of
others on it as I looked last night for
over fourteen thousand citations yeah
but it was topped by a paper that you
did a couple years earlier on generative
adversarial Network so also with with
Ian within and Joshua yeah and so can
you just say a little bit about what
kind what what's your affiliation is
these days how you work at UDM and milla
and what kinds of problems you're you're
thinking about sure yeah well I'm at
Miele which is an Institute studying
essentially core on deep learning but we
really cover a lot of topics of machine
learning general and and AI sort of even
more broadly and I'm at the dhole that's
are essentially our computer science and
operations research department at the
university of montreal i am i'm 100% a
faculty member I don't have any cross
appointments I am I am actually a fellow
at at element AI as well as a number of
us are and yeah so that's essentially my
I guess my affiliations I'm I'm actually
also a holder of a CCA I chair a C
far-right research chair so I'm very
happy to have that it's been something
that they've come out with recently to
help the the Canadian AI research scene
and I think it's been an excellent
initiative in fact one of MSR zone
Fernando Diaz also it has a c4 chair
that no we were it's the banquette
celebrating those yeah before we dive
into some of your your many projects I
want to just start by stepping back a
few decades and asking you how you got
started so I know you were at University
of Toronto and did your undergraduate
and master's degree there in Applied
Sciences and engineering so did you go
in with a knowledge that that's what you
wanted to do or did you drift into that
and into the interview even did neural
networks yes so I guess I mean my
background yeah so I guess I can say I
did my I went through the University of
Toronto in the engineering science of a
department or I guess it's a program
engineering science 2 program and it's a
it's a really pretty challenging program
designed for people that are really
interesting moving on and doing research
or something a little bit like that a
little later on so it's a little bit
more mathematical a little bit more on
the fundamentals of science than a
typical engineering background and I I
really enjoyed it I thought was an
excellent background and in preparation
for for research moving forward the then
I got interested in my Master's work I
got interested in biomedical engineering
and that's kind of where I started
looking at studying neurons and neural
nets and these kinds of things and
seeing the connection from there and
then from there I went on to do my PhD
work at Carnegie Mellon University with
David Trotsky as my supervisor and yeah
and we got really interested in
questions of classical conditioning and
these kinds of things so yeah did you go
into your undergraduate degree with a
focus on engineering or did you somehow
drift into that based on my undergrad no
I think I've always wanted to do
something along the lines of science and
engineering it was ever since I could
remember this is what I love doing so I
was very focused on that it was it was
figuring out what I wanted to do after
that the kind of I also kind of knew I
wanted to be a research even though I
I didn't as even as an undergrad I
didn't really have a good idea what that
what a research it did yeah exactly I
just I just love searching for things
and like you know puzzling through
questions and trying to find answers and
and so I you know before I even knew
what it was I knew that that's what I
want to do in terms of these specific
topics that I did a lot more sort of
falling into it like I said the the
biomedical engineering I I I saw a
presentation by who would become my
master supervisor barish Braddock Ian
and he kind of just captivated my
imagination about about the kinds of
problems that that were interested in
and actually he got me with a quote from
Einstein something along the lines of
you know I want to know God's thoughts
the rest are details so I thought that
was really impressive and so yeah that's
I got into that it was I thought really
nice because it there's a certain
elegance to and and beauty to the design
in biology and I thought studying that
if I was interested in in engineering I
thought studying you know elements of
design that really are very successful
seemed like a good thing to do so I mean
it's interesting that from from a design
perspective you you chose living
organisms which are way more complex
than things like bridges or skyscrapers
right and as you mentioned you did your
PhD at CMU and one of the things I I
feel in this era is that you took
actually a really interdisciplinary
approach to intelligence and modeling
you know bringing perspectives from
neuroscience and computational
perspective yeah and your thesis
committee kind of reflects that yeah I
guess in addition to David turetsky it
had Peter Diane McClellan yes yeah Jeff
Gordon a really rich set of appreciative
very I was very happy to have them all
there actually I was really contributed
I felt very much to my the betterment of
my thesis and I really enjoyed having
the one that my committee so let me talk
a little bit about your your thesis
during the early 2000 she published a
series of papers at nipsey's as it was
called it at the time looking at both
classical and operant conditioning and
trying to model temporal
trying to model similarity in
discrimination and things like that can
you tell the audience a little bit about
what classical conditioning is and what
it was in that really low level I guess
you'd talk about it a system one kinds
of processing that captivated yeah so I
guess what I found really interesting
this is one of these things where I
didn't know I would find this nearly as
interesting as I ended up finding it but
I kind of got captured by there's
there's something like a hundred years
of experiments by really it's excellent
experimentalists on looking at
phenomenon behind animal learning and
what we're talking about is the kind of
very simple learning phenomena they know
it's a very simple level it's like
Pavlovian conditioning where you know
you you have a stimulus I mean you're
ringing a bell or maybe you're having a
buzzer and then you present some sort of
reinforcement either either a foot shock
or maybe you're presenting food like a
little squirt of juice or something like
that and then the animal learns the
connection between these things so as
far as it goes that's pretty simple and
we have very simple models that can
describe that but it gets much more
interesting when you start to vary the
connections between them or if you have
like a temple varying pattern between
the stimuli and the rewards and what we
found was that the there was really well
what I felt to me at the time to be a
very rich pattern of what they were
learning and and I felt like we could
describe it and the only way I in fact I
could make any sense of it was to
actually you know present a fairly
sophisticated model of Bayesian
conditioning where they were positing
different hypotheses about the world and
they would have to sort of vie between
different competing hypotheses about the
world depending upon how much data they
were so this is a latent variable model
of yeah that's right that's right so
yeah so though can you describe like one
of the phenomenon that you were trying
to model right okay sure yeah so there's
this interesting connection I guess this
is the only one I probably remember very
well at this point but there's um let's
see there's this one pattern where you
can if you shine a light let's so light
and then you present some sort of
reinforcement and let's cut let's say
many of the cases I ended up studying
the reinforcement for better for worse
as a foot shock so
the animal freezes that's the kind of
responses we're talking about a mouse or
a rat here so you shine a light and you
present the the reinforcement and you
get off after a while you get a freezing
response then if you present the light
and then atone together without the foot
shock but you only present a few of
examples of light and tone then you
present the tone alone the animal will
freeze expecting the foot shocks but if
you present a lot more examples of light
and tone and together with light and
foot shock then the animal learns
eventually that the tone actually means
inhibition of foot shock and so when you
present a richer representation super
interest and then this this tension
between these two things where the where
the tone first becomes a predictor of
FERC shock until eventually becomes a
predictor of inhibition of foot shock so
it's not just that it predicts no foot
shock it actually predicts that a foot
shock won't happen even when presented
with something that normally would
predict foot shock so it's it's vey
weighing those competing hypotheses
against one another that we felt that
well we found that a model of a Bayesian
model actually ended up well describing
the animal behavior very well okay and
so actually I looked last night that you
one is the best student paper award and
for this work on similarity and
discrimination does it after just a
minute ago does it bear any resemblance
to the kind of back and forth in that
you see in Ganz where you have both a
generator and a discriminator or where
they largely disconnected I I didn't I
didn't it didn't occur to me that there
was a similarity there until you
mentioned it I I guess yeah I guess
there I would I don't know in my head
they occupy very different spaces on the
one hand they're they're like we have
just this Bayesian model on the other
hand it's a very different kind of a
learning process this kind of
competitive learning process between the
generator and the discriminator so like
they're tackling in some sense
phenomenon that that talk both about
similarity and generalizability yeah
yeah for sure that's that's that's very
true yeah good so thanks that that was
really it's fun to reflect I I hope for
you on some of the the early work
after you got your PhD you spent several
years in Montreal with with yahshua and
it was sort of at the at the time when
ideas around deep learning and even Mila
we're starting to take shape so can you
reflect a little bit on what the lab was
like when you started like who else was
there how it evolved sure must have been
just this hotbed of well it was really
interesting so so when I I should say
that I you know I finished my PhD and my
my wife and I moved to Montreal I guess
I should say my partner and i were
montreal and because she got a job at
McGill University this is Joelle Pino
and so so I arrived not having finished
my thesis so I spent almost a year just
writing up my thesis while staying in a
visitor's office at McGill and then I
finished that and I sort of started
looking around for what what I'm going
to do next and Joshua was there and I
met with him and he was generous enough
to take me in as a postdoc you know I I
had not done the kind of work he was
really focused on I was coming out doing
my my classical conditioning modeling
but he took a chance on me and I was
very thankful for that and yeah so so I
remember after having arrived I feel
like this was you know very shortly
after arrived after a few months that I
was walking by his office and he kind of
emerged from his office and we was
saying that you know he was just on the
phone with with with Jeff and Yann and
Entering and they're starting a new
field that's going to be called deep
learning
okay make much of it at the time but and
all day that's exactly what they went
and did and then so they started really
focusing on this question of
representation learning and learning
deeper layered models and stuff like
that of course at the time you know
these methods didn't work very well we
didn't yet have the tools really to make
these things trainable and and that was
a series of innovations that from that
time right
from from early those early days where
we had you know the only kind of method
that really worked reasonably well in
this direction was this kind of was was
this greedy why he's pre training where
we would train layer by layer yeah and
then from there you know the methods got
better and better but yeah that so you
know the kind of PhD students he had at
the time were you know Michele was there
later a little later on we had a good
fellow and eventually I became his co
supervisor but yeah so Niccolo know who
was around Demetri air hound was another
PhD student there so we had up we did
have a really good group of students in
the lab that's for sure so yeah some of
your work from from that period one of
them that that really stood out to me is
the work that I guess wound up
eventually in JM LR but was may be
presented at AI stats on unsupervised
pre-training right right and sort of you
know how it how it works you did a lot
of I guess work on simulation yeah
deeply try not can you describe that and
how it it compares you like a probably a
decade later is some of the work that's
going on in future well so so I think
that we were very much focused on this
question of this of this layer wise
greedy layer wise pre-training and kind
of asking this question of why does this
work and that was that's a funny paper
because at least from my perspective I
don't know if yahshua would would would
agree with them my perspective but but
from my perspective it was a paper that
essentially came out of like a an
intellectual argument between him and I
as as to what was the real underlying
phenomenon here was it was it
predominantly a regularization method we
were looking at or was it predominantly
a means of helping the the the the model
optimize and we would sort of go back
and forth this which one I was I think I
was advocating the the regularization
strategy point of view he was advocating
the the the optimization point of view
and we would in this kind of going back
and forth we would sort of design
experiments to try to see which one of
these would work and and that paper was
essentially the outcome of that process
so regularization then the other
generalization turned out to
well come on take it well I think that
yeah that at the time I think that ended
up being what that kind of pre-training
was although I will say that that his
hunch in the long term was very much
right and that what we needed were
models that more effective means of
actually optimizing these these models
across these many layers of
representation and I don't think we
really had that at the time but but
ultimately he was very much right in
that that was that's exactly what was
needed to make these models really
perform the way that they eventually
found how's it related to some of the
pre-training that we see today
especially in the context of large-scale
language models yeah so so it's I think
it's somewhat somewhat similar in that
we're seeing the same kind of idea being
used well it's actually I think it's
different because there we really did
face this issue of not being able to
train these models and to end if these
kind of deep layered models right so
what we would do is we would train them
a piece at a time starting at the bottom
and it's this kind of auto either an
auto coder or you know a restricted
Boltzmann machine that kind of model and
then we would just stack these up on top
of one another I see so you train them
sequentially yes
very much we train them sequentially in
a greedy little era and then and then of
course we would fine-tune them at the
end back propagating through so so to
sum so that has stayed but of course if
you dig down inside at what we found was
that during our fine-tuning phase only
very few of the top layers would
actually see much in the way of
adaptation the bottom layers wouldn't
really move very much so we're really
relying on this this greedy woman why
greedy layer wise pre-training to do
something sensible with the bottom
layers there but nowadays the reason why
you do a lot of these in specially for
these big language models the reason why
you're doing a lot of this pre-training
is because we don't really have a so
much of the same problem of as training
these many layers but they're it's more
of a question of the amount of data you
have you have an enormous model you want
to be able to train these enormous set
of parameters on a very large data set
and then you can fine-tune that that
whole structure on a smaller task that
has very little data but because you've
you've built this really
these really useful set of features
using a large data set you can then you
know adopt those models those data those
parameters a little bit in order to get
really good performance about
state-of-the-art performance on a lot of
these language modeling tasks yeah I'll
get to this later I want to talk a lit
the end a little bit more about sort of
modularity and and how when one thinks
about models evolving over time but I
wanted you know shortly after this it
seems like you are at the center of the
deep learning universe at that time and
I I gotta say I think I got very very
lucky yeah this is not any great insight
on my part this is just I happen to be
there it's literally the best I think I
can say about it is I just happened to
be there you know yahshua had this
vision and I thought I think it was it
was he turned out to be very much right
about that vision but for a lot of us I
mean it's both an issue of opportunity
and then seizing the moment right you
sure you could have been there and and
done very different things that you know
I look back at my career and I made a
few choices about going to industry
versus university going coming to
Microsoft about took more than 20 years
ago now and those were not particularly
well planned and thought-out
trajectories I did have one but it was
not what I wound up choosing and so in
your case it sounds similar you sort of
happened on to an amazing situation in
Montreal and we're part of its success
and I continue to be today you're
clearly a real leader at Mila and and
more broadly in the deep learning
community so you en and and Joshua at
some point decided to write the deep
learning book yeah why what does it well
I think Joshua was approached actually
by MIT press about writing a book like
this and at the time we were thinking
that well there's like reasons to read
and reasons not to read it reason not to
read it would be that the field that was
evolving very quickly and it was
evolving very quickly then and so we
knew that we were going to face a
certain amount of risking a certain
amount of obsolescence by writing it
when we did
but at the same time there were there is
a lot of people getting into the field
so there were a lot of people that had a
technical background maybe they were
scientists or engineers but were new to
the field entirely and so we that's
really who we were focused on writing
this is the next generation of both
practitioners and researchers
practitioners and researchers and mainly
we were looking at for these people
coming into the field not necessarily
for for sort of first-year students
although we're writing it with them in
mind as well
but mainly we were that's the that's why
we decided to write it when we did is
because we felt like there was a
tremendous demand for this kind of
knowledge and and just going in and
reading papers can be a little bit
daunting as like in terms of knowing
which papers need and and sort of
sifting through that literature can be
can be a pretty daunting task so yeah
we've felt like maybe despite the issue
of the field not having been far from
being settled it seems like the right
time so if you were to look back it's
only been four years I guess that's it
is there any of the framing that you
would do differently what's the biggest
surprise what's the biggest change that
you didn't really capture in that book
well I I don't know if we were in the
end that's surprised because we were
writing it around the time and we were
starting to see this transition so so
both like pre around you know just on
while we were writing the books you know
the dominant mode in in at least the
research side of deep learning was very
much on these restricted Boltzmann
machines and those kinds of methods
still very much focused on this greedy
layer wise training but we were seeing
that the field was moving away from that
pretty pretty quickly and so I think
that's the part of the book that I would
say you know in retrospect maybe I would
have put less emphasis on that because
nowadays in at least if you look at the
research being presented there's there's
relatively little of that in there in
the you know in the research world you
know researcher Boltzmann machines are a
lot less popular than they were but at
the same time you know we were around we
were writing the book around the same
time
like you know Gans were around they made
it in their walls like variational
autoencoders were around and they made
it in there so so a lot of the
fundamentals that were there are still
fundamentals now there are very much the
basis of a lot of ongoing work were
around so I mean in some sense we got a
little lucky there too like nothing has
gone around and made it all completely
irrelevant but I think you're right I
mean more and more people are training
in to end and you know not thinking as
much maybe about the individual
components
yeah there's kind of a there's both a
win in a you know a plus and a minus -
that's right because I think you know
when you train an to end it's not clear
how you transfer it to a new task
already that's right that's right yeah I
think that's absolutely true and and I
think the we're now you know with work
like the under all modular Network
something like that people are coming
back to sort of realizing that the
structure actually matters inside and
and and thinking about the kinds of
structure that you can impose by you
know sub swapping in different
components right and hopefully getting
some sort of generalization benefit from
that process yeah so we're now looking
at those kinds of questions let me use
that as a transition to to just think
about some of the the next directions in
your work I mean the last decade has
been absolutely amazing in terms of the
achievements in deep learning especially
in vision speech languaging increasingly
you know I think it's hard for people
who experience things like search
engines or autocomplete smart reply
real-time speech recognition and
generation to think about the fact that
it was only you know it's only within
the last decade that systems have been
getting good enough to support those
kinds of interactions in the wild these
are not just static test collections and
I think a lot of what we do you know day
to day with personal assistants with
search engines with even sensing in cars
and stuff has really been driven by the
the methods that you were you know a
large part of shaping about data and of
compute but there are also a ton of
challenges that in in applying these and
idle off a few of my my own favorite
there they have to do with robustness
the fragility in the the real-world
sample in efficiency things like and you
just diluted to this you know grounding
representations thinking about bringing
in maybe the best of symbolic and neural
systems what are some of your current
research directions and how do they fit
into shaping will say the next decade of
system so I guess though one of the
things that we're really interested in
in addressing these days and my group is
well what I like to call systematic
generalization so this is a term that's
really grown out of more out of the NLP
community but you know it's related to
notions of causality and these ideas
like this where we're interested in
maybe learning from a particular data
distribution but then being able to
generalize effectively beyond that
distribution and of course what that
means is something we're still trying to
formalize and and make sense of because
you know just generalizing to any
arbitrary distribution and any pattern
of mapping between your input and your
output is isn't is not something that's
realistic or sensible to even ask for
but but if if from the training data you
do have if you can imagine learning a
sense of a set of rules or a kind of a
pattern of regularities that you can
then generalize beyond that that initial
distribution that's really the kind of
thing we're looking at what kinds of
problems are you you looking at there is
it so you know I think about the non
stationarity of the world yeah and it
could be the same model in the same task
over time it could be generalizing to a
related task there are lots of
dimensions of generalizability right so
we've been focused on this particular
topic we've been focused on the new
kinds of combinations so so the specific
question and we're doing this in in
fairly toyish domains
so looking at for example we wrote a we
defined this new question answering data
set this is work with the first authors
Dima Dima about an O and what we did was
we well we developed this scoop data set
where it's essentially very simple forms
in the input and we're asking very
simple questions about the spatial
relationships between these elements of
the input and you know certain patterns
were deliberately missing from the
training set and we would ask questions
about that pattern and the test set and
seeing is are these different models
able to generalize to this unique
pattern that was not observed in the
training set so and and you know
different kinds of models performed
differentially on that kind of a task
decide what dimensions you want
generalization over yeah is there a way
to systematically explore them well for
this for this particular case we're
relying heavily on notions of
compositionality so we want our models
to recognize that the world is composed
of certain elements and that if it
observes you know a small number of
freely associating compositional
elements that it should be able to
generalize to other combinations that
haven't been observed so this is the
kind of generalization is our systematic
generalization we'd like to see in
natural language which we don't
currently have our current models they
can perform amazing on certain specific
tasks but you can pretty easily make
them look foolish by just changing the
the kinds of inputs they receive yes to
something that is perfectly
understandable by a human and yet very
unlikely to be close to something that
they've seen in their data set and they
can interpret that you know in a very
wrong way yes I mean it's clear that in
certainly adversarial settings and even
not in adversarial settings you can
perturb stimuli and in small ways and
have to a human and have really huge
differences for a learn system so what
is it
algorithmically that that you're doing
is that uh I mean is it a form of
regular regularization or priors or how
do you think about modeling some of the
the ways in which you want to generalize
right so in this work we're looking more
at different kinds of architectures so
we're looking at for example these
neural modular networks that came out
principally of the work of Jakob andreas
yeah and we've looked at other models
there's this this Mac model that came
out of out of Chris Manning's group at
Stanford and then there's so we have
this model film which is sort of all of
these models were kind of developed to
compete on this clever data set so
clever is is essentially a synthetic
question-answering data set so we've
actually gone on this is also work led
by edema about a known we've gone on and
and he's actually found some some holes
in clever so we so that aren't actually
in the clever data set but we can test
oh I see so comp specific combinations
of question types sub question types and
so we can actually test for this kind of
systematic generalization in within the
clever environment and on clever types
of questions and there we actually see
some interesting things that like for
example we find that our film model
doesn't generalize systematically very
well at all much to my dismay but Mack
actually does a fairly decent job with
that kind of generalization and we're
also finding that certain forms of these
neural module networks actually do also
a very good job that's kind of where
we're we're seeing most of the promise
actually in those kinds of modular
models which makes sense it's
interesting if you go back to some of
the work in in neural modeling that
happened at Bell Labs when yawn and and
Yahshua I guess were there you know
cnn's were the real workhorse there and
but they were not learned in a
completely unstructured way they were a
lot of prior there were a lot of
structural elements that were based on
human physiology how do you how do you
think more and how do you think more
generally about combining priors or
knowledge or structure that we have some
insights about with more bottom-up
induct
learning I think there's a real art to
it I think so
so commnets I think are a beautiful
model they're one of my favorite
examples of a this compromise between
the the flexibility of some of allowing
a model to kind of learn what it wants
to learn well at the same time adding
some sort of prior knowledge about the
kind of domain you want to apply apply
to and you can see that there's been
actually quite a bit of work follow-on
work from the comments trying to improve
it in various ways and I think they've
had yet to really have an impact on
improving that that structure yeah I
just think that's because it you know
the original model was very well
designed in terms of that compromise and
it's been very difficult to find clearly
better alternative but we've lost we
certainly lost some of that art maybe
they were lucky maybe it was you know
people with understanding of the problem
I'm not sure we lost it okay I think we
continue to do this right I mean I think
it's people that go and study the the
details of the problem that come up with
things like like transformer networks
and things like this so I think we're
still in this process of uncovering you
know what are the best types of models
to handle certain kinds of data yeah so
really characterizing much better the
space of applications and data and need
to generalize in ways that that are
really very prevalent and in the open
world you talked earlier about your work
in classical conditioning and and that's
a very simple low-level process very
very simple and even there there were
complexities about furies of elements
and you think about you know kids
learning language and really the real
world where they're looking at just this
flurry of information that comes
multimodal II I should say I should back
up and say yeah the the the models that
the the experiments that were run and
the models I used were very simple but
the if you look at the pattern of
behavior it really does seem like the
the kind of cognitive tools that the
animals are bringing to bear are
actually very sophisticated I mean we
had a real hard time building models
that could actually match the animal
performance and you know with with
whatever resources we have available to
us at the time and in the sense of of
being able to so say for example animals
seem to be able to learn the specific
temporal pattern of of information and
integrate that with certain amount of
temporal variance in ways that it's
would still be difficult to do that
today so I think yeah I think we're
we're still you know it would still I
know I haven't attempted this for many
years but but I think it would still be
a challenge to actually you know match
the actual pattern of animal performance
on these tasks from a modeling
perspective right having a single model
that matched that that that pattern of
it's interesting because they're the
observations are in a more of a
laboratory setting and so you don't see
a lot of the rest of the world you don't
have that that's right it's very much
abstracted away right but like I said
these experimentalists and again there's
like a hundred years of experimental
data on this on this topic but you know
they've gone in and are able to very
precisely manipulate the kind of the
different kinds of patterns to
differentiate different theories of the
phenomenon that they're studying are we
gonna need to do that for some of the
deep learning models to succeed or yeah
it's a very interesting question
actually and I think it wouldn't be too
surprising to me if we if we were to get
there eventually where we start
considering and we're already starting
to see papers along these lines right
we're studying these these deep models
more as as phenomena in and of
themselves rather than just sort of
tools to accomplish a task
thanks it's so this different really for
me a fun you know fun opportunity to
hear a little bit more about how you got
where you are the kinds of questions
that are that you're using right looking
at right now with with students and
collaborators of all kinds to really I'd
say make our current understanding of
deep learning models or more robust to
make their performance in an open world
in a multimodal world
one that blends in in your case in
particular vision and language a little
bit more stable and predictable do you
have want to close with one question do
you have any advice for students who are
now getting into this field and in terms
of picking problems what kind of
background do they need to be successful
you've got a pretty atypical life and
does that bring interesting insights you
know where are we in the neuro in the
cognitive neuroscience perspective or
something yeah so it's an actually it's
kind of interesting I I would have
thought that you know that the that we
might be you know that the insights
coming from cognitive science are
relatively well there were let's say
they weren't where they were a few you
know a few decades ago okay this field
but actually in the talk I'll be giving
later today we're actually borrowing
some ideas from cog sigh again and
applying them in in the context of AI so
so maybe not maybe yeah there's there's
this idea that's developed by somebody
in the cognitive sciences by mainly by
Simon and Kirby on iterated learning and
it's it's essentially about how it's a
theory of how language emerged and how
and specifically how compositionality
emerged in the context of language
emergence and yeah so we apply this to
to essentially counter language drift in
in these models so it's it's a bit
surprising to us that works as well as
you go back and forth between some
objective and yeah between but well
without giving away everything but we go
back and forth between the in an
interactive dialogue task and which of
course if you just were to do that by
itself there's this phenomenon called
language drift that occurs
and we know about that and so and but
then we go back and forth between that
and a kind of supervised learning so a
more standard way to do this would be
just to have some fixed data set and do
standard supervised learning on that but
instead what we do is we actually
collect data from the from the agents
that are involved in the iterative
learning and then train on that data and
that actually still helps to control
language so that's gonna be much sparser
and well it's yes less prevalent and
yeah it's it's it's it's weird that it
works in a sense the reason well the
reason why it works we can we can I I
won't speculate on here but but we see
that it has something to do with the
fact that there's this kind of
supervised learning bottleneck that when
you transfer the knowledge from the
teacher to this student it it seems to
the regularization process that comes
about by that that that learning step
seems to be helpful for us yeah it's
it's but it is really kind of unusual
that it works so we can get into it more
maybe more
well that's for folks who won't be with
us this afternoon when you give the talk
we will make it available on the MSR
network for everybody to take here more
great Aaron so let me get back to the
the question that I asked just a few
minutes ago about advice to new students
who are thinking about getting into deep
learning both from an applications
perspective as well as to provide sort
of more foundational theory in right so
I guess I mean I'm a professor so I I
get new students coming in all the time
and i one thing i can say is that it is
a bit different now than it was back
when I was a student I think both fir on
the positive side there's there's many
more opportunities for students to have
all kinds of play all kinds of roles
back when I was a student it was
relatively rare for someone to go out
and actually me to actually have a
career in research you essentially
needed to become professor
somewhere for that that was still true
when I was a student unless you were
lucky enough to get one of these a
research position in industry which was
also a relatively rare thing nowadays
most of my students I think are
expecting to have a research position
somewhere mostly in industry because
that that's as a sector that has grown
much much larger but also in some times
in academia and I think so I think
that's great I think it's a much many
more opportunities are available for
these students but at the same time I
think there's there's a certain amount
of anxiety for these students coming in
because they there's just I it's a huge
field and nur UPS has grown to be like
you know 14,000 people I think was the
last one is just like when my first
nurse was I think maybe a thousand
people so where was it - yeah it was
Breckenridge and I guess Boulder Boulder
a lot of it yeah so anyway yeah I mean
it was just it's a very very different
world now and and there's a certain like
I said there's a certain amount of
anxiety that comes in with that but I
guess my advice to them is do you know
follow a topic that you're interested in
see it through if you can to some sort
of end and and you know it's important
that you develop your own perspective on
things right don't just kind of follow
the whims of the day just to take time
and study a problem and develop your own
perspective because you know we're still
very much in early stages of trying to
understand these things and and you know
you know yours any one of you any one of
these students are gonna have just a
good a chance as anyone that uncovers
something important about the next the
next generation of these models you said
a couple of things that I just want to
end by reflecting on one is take your
time so I think students are often feel
pressured to submit for paper 40 papers
to nip nervous or any other conference
and the second is follow your passion
mm-hmm where more and more these methods
are applicable to everything we do not
just esoteric you know research problems
ideas can be applied to
climate change the societal good and so
I think there's a huge opportunity for
for students to have an impact yeah
absolutely I think it's absolutely true
ok so slow down and follow your passion
yeah yeah I think I think you know all
advice can be can be measured but I
think that that is basically what I
believe you okay
thanks Aaron great having you here
you